each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright thanks so right this is a talk
on a new project about how to program
networks and it's new but we've got a
bunch of people that we've managed to
get excited about it and here they are
so one of the the real leaders of the
project is Nate Foster who is a postdoc
at Princeton but now he started as an
assistant professor at Cornell we also
have professors Mike Friedman and Jen
rexford they do networking Nate and I do
programming languages Rob as a master
student Chris and is a graduate student
marks a graduate student and alex is an
undergrad okay so traditional networks
are collections of switches connected
together with the goal of forwarding
packets and if you look inside one of
these switches and you'll typically see
an organization that looks something
like this so there's a bunch of hardware
that has a responsibility of trying to
forward filter buffer rate limit packets
at great speed and then there is that's
called the data point and then there is
another layer of software often called
the control plane that tracks the
topology of the network computes routes
and tells the data plane what kinds of
forwarding rules it should employ ok and
then typically off to the side there's a
what might be called a management plane
perhaps it's a person perhaps it's a
program new job it is to monitor the
traffic network wide and to configure
the the switches so that they obey the
policies that are expected so a recent
idea in networking is to think about
whether or not we can actually remove
the control plane software from those
switch boxes so the idea is to take that
control plane
we're and move it into some general
purpose computer outside of the boxes
and the advantages of doing this are so
that companies can buy the simple
forwarding hardware and then implement
their own control software to that can
be customized for their own applications
and their own needs so one of the ideas
is by making these boxes simpler they're
going to be cheaper they're actually
going to be more flexible the same
hardware box that you know would be
called a router could be could be a
switch it could be a net firewall or
some new innovative combination of any
of those things and for a company like
Microsoft you might be happy that you
don't have to spend you know millions of
dollars or a million dollars buying that
special-purpose load balancer that is
manufactured by some company like Cisco
a lot of the networking researchers I
think both in industry and in academia
are really excited by this idea because
they hope that it's going to lead to a
lot of innovation in design of networks
so that idea has been realized in a
system called open flow so open flow
started in at Stanford and it's a
protocol that allows these switches
which are now simplified so that they
just contain the data plane to
communicate with what we'll call a
controller machine which again is one of
these general process general-purpose
computers running some control and
management software and these
general-purpose computers now are going
to be responsible for monitoring network
traffic tracking the topology of the
network deciding on routes and
communicating with these switches to
tell them what kinds of forwarding
tables they should install so open flow
right now has a lot of momentum so
there's recently development of a
consortium called the open networking
foundation and all of the big IT
companies that you know and love such as
Microsoft Google Facebook Cisco have
signed on with the idea that they're
going to real
is this new vision of separating out the
control plane from the forwarding
hardware okay so open flow is great
because it's going to make programming
networks which is possible but it still
is not going to be an easy programming
task the openflow interface is a very
thin veneer over the switch hardware and
it still presents a number of really
challenging programming problems and so
the goal of our research is to develop
language supports that facilitates this
kind of network programming we want to
build new abstractions that programmers
bind easy to use that allow them to make
their programs more module or more
reliable more secure okay so that's sort
of the intro and the rest of the talk
i'm going to tell you a little bit more
about open flow and a particular kind of
controller platform knox and a little
bit more more depth i'm going to try to
communicate to you some of the existing
problems with the programming model i'm
going to tell you a little bit about our
new proposal for a new language for
programming these things and some of the
new abstractions that we think are
necessary for network programming and
then i'm going to tell you a little bit
about how our implementation works and a
little bit about our experience in this
space so far yep
so right so so a long time ago this is
active networks kind of research being
so inactive networks one of the ideas
was where that packets we're going to be
carrying code and that packets we're
going to roam around the networks and
the switches we're going to interpret
the packets and then load new code onto
them and dumb and is done in a
centralized manner on a separate
controller machine that has a lot of
smarts and has a separate control
network to tell the dumb switches here
the tables that you should implement
okay so right so step one is open flow
and Knox and a bit more depth so you can
understand the existing program model
and a couple of the problems that arise
so here's our network of switches inside
each of these switches you've got what
we'll call a flow table and a flow table
is just a list of rules and what's a
rule a rule is a combination of some
kind of pattern that matches typically
the headers of a of a packet so it might
be an exact match pattern it specifies
an exact pattern for the for some of the
headers or it might be some kind of wild
card pattern that specifies the prefix
and matches anything else that follows
so in addition to a pattern for matching
packets there's an action associated
with each rule so an example action
might be just drop the packet another
action might be forward the packet at
this port number n and another kind of
action might be I don't know what to do
with this packet send it to the
controller it's going to do some complex
decision making to figure out what to do
and potentially install more rules in me
so in addition to having these rules
associated with every single rule are a
couple of counters so there's a counter
that counts the number of bytes that
have been processed by this rule and
there's a counter that counts the number
of the total number of packets that have
been processed by this rule so just an
important thing to remember is that
these counters are explicitly associated
with individual rules in order to figure
out which rules match basically they're
prioritized and so the packet will come
in and match the highest priority rule
and then ignore the other rules okay so
what's a controller platform like Knox
look like okay well basically most of
Knox is giving you an interface to this
open flow open flow protocol that
communicates with the switches and there
are interface elements that you allow
you to install a new rule in one of the
switches uninstall one of the rules in
the switches or ask for the statistics
that are associated with the rule in
addition Knox manages a few other kinds
of events that your controller
application can respond to examples of
events are things like there's a packet
that if it's come in from a particular
switch or there's been some kind of
change in the topology of the network
for instance the switches going down its
which has come up or one of the ports on
the switches has gone up or down
so the tables you can match on is like
seven different fields in a packet you
can match on a source MAC address
destination MAC address source IP
address so it can be level 2 or level
three protocols that you can implement
in this kind of system
so I think it's level two level three
and open flow is something that's in
progress and so right now there's a
particular set of headers that you can
match on but there's more proposals out
there to allow you to match on other
things and more flexible but I think
right now you just need to know that
we're going to match on headers of
various different kinds okay so I sort
of a typical kind of application is one
in which a packet comes in to one of the
switches and then the switch says I
don't know what to do with it it sends
the packet up to the controller the
controller does a bunch of processing on
the packet and then after a little while
it decides aha to handle packets of this
kind what we need to do is install a
whole bunch of forwarding rules on each
of these switches and so that now that
more packets when more packets at the
same shape arrive they don't have to go
to the controller they go very fast
through the fast path just through
hardware so that's a typical kind of of
application okay so now let me get to
some of the problems with the basic
programming model that not an open flow
present you with so I think one of the
most fundamental problems is that it's
impossible to do any reasonable kind of
modular programming so here's an example
of a little application that I want to
build I had it wants to have one module
that make some decisions about the
routes that are going to be installed in
the switches wants to have a separate
module that does some monitoring of the
traffic that's going on in the network
so the first module might decide you
know what I need to install a rule on
the switch that says forward all the
packets that I get import one at port
two ok now the monitoring module what it
might be interested in is it might be
interested in web traffic and basically
might want to issue a query
to say tell me about all the traffic
coming in on port one that in its
protocol header is is is referring to
TCP port 80 which is web traffic so the
problem is that the monitoring module
actually can't issue a query like that
because it can only get statistics that
are associated with the particular rules
that are installed and so in this case
the only rule that's installed is a
generic rule that says forward all the
traffic you see from port 1242 there
aren't individual rules one for the web
traffic one for this other kind of
traffic and so basically the monitoring
module can't do its job without directly
collaborating with the routing module
and getting it to and install the
correct granularity of rules let me show
you that in a different way okay so
here's a little bit of nox code you
don't really have to read the details at
all that is going to implement this
simple repeater switch that takes
packets in import one and sends the men
on port two here's another little bit of
code that implements the web monitoring
infrastructure if I want to do both of
these at the same time then what I need
is code that looks like this okay and
basically what I've done is I've taken
the blue lines here and where I have
been able to ivory used blue lines over
here in my combine monitoring and
routing program and where I've wanted to
wear have been able to have taken red
lines and reuse them and in at least one
place I've had to add something
completely new in order to disambiguate
between various rules using priorities
so the problem is basically here's to
logically separate tasks that I want to
do
in order to do them in a system like
Knox I have to lunge and mix all the
code together in a completely sort of
you know non-modular mixed-up way oh
yeah well this one here well I get did I
kiss you know it it came from both so
okay so problem number one you basically
can't implement logically separate tasks
independently you often have to mix them
all together and that's because these
logically separate tasks in some sense
share this global fixed rule space in
the switches okay a second kind of
problem is consider the following which
is sort of a variation on one of my
earlier slides we have a switch i switch
sends a packet to controller see if I do
this never know what my animations are
going to do there we go ok now the
controller analyzes the packet it
updates some state to register the fact
that it's dealt with this packet and it
installs a bunch of new packet
processing rules on the switches only
problem is maybe this link is slower and
in the meantime while it's trying to
install the rules to handle subsequent
packets there suppose we flowing through
the network a couple more packets arrive
at this switch and get funneled up to
the controller and so now the controller
if it's not programmed carefully maybe
in a confused state where it thinks that
it's handled all the packets of a
certain type because it's gone through
its process of initiating a request to
install the rule but in fact it's it's
confused and if it's not handled
carefully it could have it could make
different choices or inconsistent
choices for packets that logically
should be handled in the same way
another kind of problem is simply the
problem that efficient applications are
ones that install lots of rules on the
switches
and hence have most of the packets
traveling through the fast path but at
the same time in order to get the
controller to do various things the way
these programs are structured is they
rely on the fact that certain packets
are going to come to the controller
trigger events that the controller will
then respond to so when one is writing
some of these applications one is asking
oneself is it the case that this
particular kind of packet is going to
come up to the controller or is it
already being handled by rules in the
switches you have to keep track of where
the packets going to be are they going
to come up here are they going to stay
down there so you wind up in this sort
of two-tiered programming model where
you're trying to keep track of which
things are going where okay so those are
three problems and there are actually
more problems than that but those are
just the ones I going to focus on in
this talk and they all actually have one
common cost let's just review them again
so the first problem was non-modular
programs programming you can't divide
programs into modules where there's a
monitoring component and a forwarding
component the second problem was network
race conditions the controller sees more
events or packet than it anticipates and
the third problem was a two-tier
programming paradigm where you have to
think about will the controller be able
to see the appropriate events given the
forwarding rules that are currently
installed so I argue that the common
cause of these three problems is that
this programming paradigm has no
effective abstractions for reading
network state the only way that you can
see what's going on in the network is if
you write to the network state by
installing a particular rule that you
want and then you later on query this
the counters that are associated with
that particular rule so I'm going to
argue that what we really need to do is
we need to build higher level
abstractions that give the programmer
the illusion of being able to do a real
read of the network
and integrate those into into the
programming language right so our
solution to these problems is I suppose
in two parts one we need new
abstractions for reading the network
state and in terms of the programmer
these read should have no effect on the
forwarding policy and second we
shouldn't be in this two-tiered
programming stay where we don't know is
this packet get it gets to me is it not
going to get to me abstractly the read
should be able to see every in any
packet that they choose that's flowing
through the network so the second thing
thats related to this is in order to be
able to implement abstractions for
reading Network state we also actually
need abstractions for the forwarding
policy we can't define the forwarding
policy in terms of concrete rules that
are going to be installed in switches we
need actually to specify the policies a
higher level of abstraction that's
separated from the concrete
implementation because if we don't do
that we won't be able to implement our
abstractions for for reading and it
makes sense that we have these two
different parts reading network state
and apart for specifying the foreign
policy because these are the natural
tasks that managers do they create
forwarding policies they monitor traffic
okay so this brings us to the frenetic
programming language ok so just mention
we have abstractions for reading state
we're gonna have extract abstractions
for specifying the forwarding policy the
abstractions for reading state are going
to be realized as a query language
that's integrated into the programming
language this query language is going to
allow you to select filter and group
sets of packets or statistics about
packets and it's going to be designed so
that we can compile that query language
so that for the most part the processing
of the queries is going to be done in
hardware the second part is we're going
to have a functional stream processing
library that's going to allow us to
generate streams of high level policies
we're gonna be able to register those
policies with
switches and we're going to have
combinations for transforming splitting
merging or filtering the policies as we
like so right now Knox is based in
Python so our current implementation is
as a set of libraries also in Python
although we're looking forward to future
building a real programming language
which is jazz luton intro you know I I
don't like this whole non typed Python
anyway forget that I just go on okay so
let's let's look at some of these
frenetic queries okay so our goal here's
a little here to sway just got a couple
of ports our goal is to measure the
total bytes of traffic that arrived on
port to every 30 seconds okay so here is
our little query that does it I'm going
to say first of all select sizes meaning
i'm interested in the total bytes as
opposed to select packets or which we
mean i'm interested in the set of
packets that arise or select counts
which would indicate i'm interested in
the count of the number of packets as
opposed to the total bytes okay and then
there's a filter pattern that says I'm
interested not in all packets but only
in those packets that are coming in on
port 2 and have 80 in there tcp port and
I'd like to return the results from this
query every 30 seconds so this query is
going to generate a stream of results
which is the total number of bytes that
have flowed into port 2 concerning the
web traffic every 30 seconds
yep yep yep so right so one of the key
properties is very simple intuitively
obvious to all of you a second and
that's simply that I've been able to
tell you what this query does
independently of the rest of the program
that's using it okay something we know
and love but it's not something that you
get in current controller such as knocks
yep it returns the number of bytes in
the last 30 seconds
here's another example query the goal
here is to sign the number of packets
per host traveling through port to every
minute ok so this really looks similar
to the previous one we've got we're
going to select accounts this time
because we're interested in number of
packets not number bites we're looking
we're looking at all the packets only
those on port to this clause of our
query says we're going to group them by
source max in other words we're going to
generate a different subset for every
source MAC and then again we're going to
return the result every 60 seconds so
here's one more query sorry yeah
so by grouping I mean for each distinct
source MAC that we see I'm going to give
you a tally of the packet that have that
source MAC in their in their header so
I'm further subdividing yeah well I mean
it's embedded in Python just think of it
as a keyword just think it is Kira so
you only get to put three things here
counts packets and sizes yeah so there's
only a certain number of headers that
you can group by so as I mentioned very
briefly this this query language is
constrained because we want to be able
to implement it in the switch hardware
so be very easy to define a different
query language that just has arbitrary
code that runs over the packet headers
here but if I have arbitrary code then I
can't implement that efficiently in the
switch hardware so that's why we've
restricted this query language if you
want to implement a more sophisticated
analysis of packets you can do some
simple query of this style and then do
arbitrarily more complex sophisticated
computation basically write any Python
code you want to implement a more
sophisticated predicate if this is the
gist of where your question is going so
that so by design this is simple so it
sort of has predictable cost but in
terms of expressiveness of the language
it's not limiting because this is going
to be generating a stream and you can do
any computation you want to further
filter the stream in the controller
program but you're going to have to
realize that that's going to cost you a
lot because that's not going to be in
the fast path
okay so here is one last little query so
this query is going to look at all the
packets it's then going to group the
packets by source MAC in other words
subdivide all packets into subsets every
element of the subset is going to have
the same source MAC okay then what I'm
going to do is every time the import
changes I am going to have yet another
subset and by the way I'm going to limit
the number of packets in each of those
subsets to just one okay so this is an
example of a query that's going to allow
me to implement what they call a
learning switch which is going to learn
the port's that all of the hosts are
attached to and if a house were to move
so there at one time it was attached to
one port and then sometime later on it
gets unplugged and plugged into a
different port this split when will
notice that generate a new sub set forth
at Newport that appears and allow the
controller to see that limit one says
don't send all of the packets to the
controller but for each subset only sent
exactly one packet
of when this runs so this thing is going
to generate some abstract syntax and
it's going to be fed into a listener
that i'm going to show you in a second
and that listener is going to interpret
it and start it running on the switches
it's going to interpret it it's going to
install a bunch of rules on switches and
it's going to feed the eight of the
outputs that it sees back to the user
program so is your question of it seems
that everything runs all the time it
gives you
this one also runs every time and he
runs all the time it produces results
may runs everything back against
receiver to switch all of it run yeah it
will only it will basically what's
what's going to happen is you saw this
example examples in pictures earlier
where for instance the packet come the
first packet of a flow comes in goes up
to the controller the controller say aha
I've seen one packet now so now I'm
going to install a rule on the switch so
all the rest of the packets aren't seen
by the controller and just get forward
in our where well that's just a query to
let me go on maybe you'll you'll see
more stuff when could you just seen
these queries and give them see nothing
at you and you haven't seen them in
conjunction with policies so uh ok so
these queries or other streams get piped
into things we call listeners ok so the
simplest kind of listener is a as a
print lister ok so if i write this
program here so web query is one of the
queries we define on the previous slides
so it's a function it returns the query
and pipes the query into the print
listener so basically what happens at
runtime right is that the listener
interprets the query and actually passes
it off to a runtime system which i'll
show you some pictures of later install
those rules starts you know stalls rules
sets up loops for monitoring the rule
stats and such gets back those stats and
then just just prints them out here's
another example where i use a pair of
queries i'm going to generate the web
query i'm going to generate the host
query then i'm going to call the
function merge which takes those two
queries
puts them put specifically both these
return streams so merge takes pair of
streams and generates a stream of pairs
and then that gets piped into the
polymorphic print function that's going
to print out the stream of pairs as it
sees them okay so the the point I wanted
to make here was that queries composed
with one another and I don't have to if
I know what the web query does I don't
have to worry about you know what the
house query does the semantics of the
web query are fixed yeah so so here's my
composition right i define this thing
independently i define this thing
independently I have a Combinator it
puts them together I'm done so it's one
line of code if we go back to here i
define this one independently i define
this one independently there was no way
that I could write one line of code and
put these two things together instead I
had to throw both of these things away
and write a completely new program that
took pieces of each one and interleaved
them together
so that comes back to here where the
routing module installs a simple rule
that forwards all packets from port 1 2
port to the monitoring module wants just
a subset to wants to understand it's
just a subset of the traffic that is
processed by that one rule that's
forwarding everything from port 1 too
poor to the architecture is such that
there is a counter associated with each
individual rule so the hardware simply
doesn't keep track of the more
fine-grained information that's required
by the monitoring module you can that's
essentially what this wherever this
program that's you need to do that I
need to be careful you can do that that
I mean these are all dynamic commands
but you need to be very careful about
how you do that and you need to think
carefully about what exactly are all
these rules here and how do I get the
one rule in that exactly cuts out the
fraction
so you have to inspect mean you have to
look at specifically these rules here so
yes it's possible because our runtime
system does this so basically our
runtime system set just inspects all
this stuff inspects all this stuff and
automatically does the fusion for you
and so that's that's just we're doing
yes yes yeah yeah yep
so that's a good question let me just I
just want to go back I'm not to make
sure that I convinced Tom that what I'm
doing is useful okay okay yeah that's
right I see okay okay right God got it
yeah that's right it's still there so
this this interleaving reflects in some
sense the thinking that you have to do
oh oh this is installed okay I got to do
this thing and then I got to do this
thing and I got ya yeah that's right yep
that can definitely have a whole
distribution yeah okay good so then ya
doing it this way it's actually simpler
though than having this one first and
then doing this other one later because
you have to actually uninstall a bunch
of these this this one just works with
installing rules this one the other one
would have to be laughs date i uninstall
this rule replace it with two other rule
anyway yeah okay good so someone else
you had a question sorry any question
was oh all I'm doing is showing you so
far as composing a bunch of reeds with a
single right that's what
I've only shown that boys all right so
then we're now getting to the part of
the talk where I tell you about how to
how to generate forwarding policies okay
right so right so i talked about queries
but now i want to tell you how to
implement this simple repeater switch
okay so the first thing i do is i
declare i basically generate a data
structure that represents a bunch of
rules okay so here I've got two rules
this first rule matches on port one so i
need packets coming into port 1 i'm
going to forward the map or two
similarly any packets coming in port 2
i'm going to forward them at port 1 okay
so that's a forwarding policy it's got
packets and it's got actions and I guess
I might as well mention that it doesn't
have priorities here like the underlying
hardware has priorities and the idea is
that the semantics that such a thing is
we're going to take the union of all
actions that are specified someone's
going to come up with a question quickly
but I'll keep going into that question
comes up okay so here's a little program
that is going to install these rules on
a switch so my program does is it
listens for an event that says the
switches joined the network okay it's
going to pipe the name of the switch
into this function down here and what
this does is this is a function that
takes an individual switch and generates
a single policy for it lift says take
any simple function from t1 to t2 and
basically map it over the entire stream
okay
okay so yeah so the question you're
going to ask is what yeah there's a
conflict here like there's a forward and
a drop and it doesn't how do i what do I
do about that so our solution right now
is that we only have actions that have
positive information so we only dropping
a packet is the absence of actions so
it's the empty set of actions and so
then we can have Union be the semantics
ok that means we'd forward if this one
if this one was forwarding this one was
empty then we'd forward yeah if they if
they were on the same that they'd match
the same packet so then you ask another
question but I have a slide for that
later so the question is how do you how
do you make sure something gets dropped
that's you wish we didn't have to deal
with Python right and we had our own
good language yeah sorry uh so so
forward is a kind of action so if you
want it's a keyword no it's a specific
thing that's right import is a specific
this is a specific pattern right so
there's one different kind of pattern
for each different kind of header and
you can form conjunctions of them and
disjunctions of them and any kind of set
theoretic operation you want and our
compiler takes care of munging that into
something that the actual hardware can
process and this thing here is this a
specific kind of policy data structure
okay sorry for not making that i should
i can highlight or something like that
oh i just want to say that typically
what we do to write programs is we write
functions that generate streams of
policies ok so then what we do is when
we have such a stream of policies we at
the very top level only we will pipe
that into the register listener and the
register listener will have the job of
implementing that stream of policies in
this in the order that they appear in
the stream so basically this this will
install a whole bunch of rules on our
switches to implement this policy yeah
basically there's an underlying runtime
system that has a global view of
everything and its job is to stitch the
different parts together for the
programmer and I think the well one of
the nice contributions of this work is
you know taking a sort of conventional
idea from programming languages so you
can have a global runtime system like a
garbage collector and that can basically
take care of a lot of details and
bookkeeping for you and that's what's
going on here except instead of managing
memory we're managing the rule space on
the switches for you a policy is a
collection of rules oh yeah let's just
go with that okay so here's how we
implement the stats monitor and the
repeater write one line of code for the
repeater policy one line of code for the
stats query the runtime system handles
the count the composition of them
underneath the covers you don't have to
do anything
so here is what you would do if you
wanted to have if you wanted to be sure
that you're dropping certain packets you
have might have one module the repeater
module that implements a string of
policies then what you do is write a
wrapper around it that looks at the
stream of policies and subtracts out
some set of rules that are involved with
packets that have bad IP so here's a
fictitious example so secure as a
function it takes into policy stream and
there's some other function that's going
to generate a stream of bad IP addresses
for me those the IP addresses that are
sending packets that I don't want to
allow those guys to send packets I'm
going to pair this dream with my policy
stream and then I'm going to apply this
filter IPS function that takes a set of
IP is at a policy and basically just
subtract out any rules that involve
these IP addresses from the policy so if
the initial policy said forward this
guide to some particular place this
function would delete that rule delete
that part of the policy from from the
overall policy and so then I can go
ahead apply secure to this repeater I
could ply secure to any kind of routing
policy that I want again it's very
modular pipe it into register so the
main point here is that this is nothing
you knew i'm just doing sort of ordinary
functional programming and the reason i
can do that is just because we have
these policies its data structures
floating around and i can go ahead and
process them just use the ordinary
programming yep
so this is a stream of policies I've
computed it no on the controller machine
so this all of this everything but the
queries basically runs on the controller
machine and the controller machine
computes the policies that you want to
install on the switches so this is a
stream of policies when it gets the
first policy in the stream the register
function is going to implement that yeah
a policy yes but a policy you can have a
packet come up to the controller the
controller program can analyze that
packet and can make a dynamic decision
about to construct some new policy yeah
exactly so those rules your salon that's
the policy it's a feedback with
no yep yep it's not as I don't think
it's a semantic problem it's just I mean
there's two separate levels there's a
there's a cast running through the
network and then some of those go to the
controller i mean we're developing a
semantics as we speak so when you write
a query you can say something like limit
1 okay and so if you get multiple
packets coming up to the runtime system
too fast the runtime system has a
semantic information that you only
wanted one packet you'll do something
with that first packet at you know do a
drop generate some new policy and it
will consistently apply the policy to
the rest of the packets that are coming
up too fast before if you get those
rules pushed down especially this you
have higher level information so the
runtime system can handle the problem
automatically yep sorry so what you do
is you'd write a query that says query
the bad packets okay so that would
generate a stream of packets okay so
this is a stream processing language so
you can do any kind of stream processing
computation with the packet isn't the
stream of packets as an input stream
policies as an output that stream of
policies flows into the register
function
probably but if you wrote several lines
that said register our semantics would
be take the union of the actions from
all the register commands yep yep two
packets from two packets from the
different switches say or in flight
towards the controller yep yep the
second packet from being sent it would
still receive it right yeah what is the
semantics what is it granny very good um
so so that's a great question that is
work we're working on right now and
maybe I can treat that question at the
end of the talk a bit more basically
right now that we there is no such
atomicity kind of property if you get
when you install new policies on
switches and that's problematic for lots
of applications or easily can cause bugs
if you're not really really really
really careful that's just so yeah okay
yeah all right all right okay let's
let's look at the let's look at the
runtime system okay so the basic
organization looks like this you have a
user program the user program is going
to write queries and it's going to
register policies with the runtime
system the runtime system is going to
basically compile and compose the
policies and the queries generating
concrete rules that it wants to install
it's going to call various routines and
knocks to get knocks to install them for
us on the way back up there it's going
to process events that it gets from
knock such as events to tell you about
changes in
apology it's going to manage statistics
and it's going to filter packets that
arise due to various Network race
conditions it's going to synthesize all
this information it's going to generate
streams that respond to queries and
streams of status updates what how long
am i doing for time by the way five
minutes okay then I am ok that's fine I
could do it okay you're gonna miss some
parts that's right so there's a lot of
different options in terms of how you
implement this runtime system and that
makes it fun and interesting to explore
just like a garbage collector there's
lots of different garbage collector
algorithms you can imagine so here is to
choice points there's more than two one
choice point is what's the granularity
of rules that you're going to install on
the switches you can install what's
called micro flow rules that's exact
match rules on the source which is this
is simpler to manage but you get many
many more rules you've got one rule for
every different bit pattern and header
that you see or you can try to generate
wildcard rules that match large swaths
of the packet space here it's more
computation is involved in figuring out
what wildcard rules you want to generate
it's more complicated and but you could
potentially generate many fewer rules
which is important because switch state
switch space is a limited resource and
also if you do it using micro flow rules
there's a don't worry about the response
time for microphone for micro flow so in
terms of rule installation you can also
be lazy or you could be eager so
basically lazy is you wait for packets
to come to the controller before you
start installing rules Proactive is you
see what your policy as you try and
install rules in advance so the packets
don't come to the controller at all
frenetic version 1 point 0 take this
choice which is the same choice as
typically the Stanford folks who
developed open flow
take in there manually written programs
but my colleagues and others think that
that's unrealistic in many many settings
and so we're doing additional work end
it on a second runtime system that takes
this more efficient approach okay so i'm
not going to show you any of that stuff
which is really exciting but i can tell
you individually because i'm here for a
week so we've got some preliminary
experience we've basically copied
several of the algorithms that are
distributed vanilla in this knocks
library Learning switch spanning tree
shortest paths rotating a DHCP server
ARP server and we've cut up a few
additional apps ourselves we definitely
need a lot more experience though we've
done a little bit of performance
modeling but we haven't optimized a
runtime and we need really a better test
bed for measure the performance and the
throughput of our controller so in terms
of what's up next one of the things that
I'm really excited about is the fact in
this first piece of work we develop new
abstractions for weeds basically as shaz
asking this question we also need new
abstractions for or new semantics for
updates to network state for example one
can imagine one's implementing you know
one has one switch that is in charge of
being a firewall and when you update
policy is you want to make sure that
your updates aren't such that
accidentally a packet does not go
through that fire wall switch because of
the order in what you're updating rules
and this sort of thing could certainly
happen if you're not very very clear
about exactly the order in which you
update the rules so we'd like to give
people some higher-level operations for
doing atomic updates and we have some
ideas for mechanisms
that we can use to actually implement
those things and give people good
high-level semantic properties we're
also interested in extending the
language so that not only does it talk
about the switches but it can also
gather information from n toasts and so
that we can have an even grander
language that not only controls the
network but control some of the aspects
of the machines that are surrounding it
we're also interested in understanding
how to reason about these programs and
ensuring that certain invariants hold
it's the last thing which I only need is
a minute you can just look it over is
that I think that there's so still
working on this but there's got to be a
nice analogy between basically
programming an x86 is to programming in
a high-level language like f sharp or C
sharp or Java like programming to knock
is to programming too frenetic these
basically high-level abstractions in
some sense arranged to do a lot of
menial bookkeeping automatically for you
and so that's that's the end I'll just
do that but you can look at that thing
yep
so this was before we figured out that
there was this the key idea was
importing these read abstractions the
actual initial idea to separate the
programming language into a query
language and general purpose computation
was to give programmers control over
costs because the query language is
limited such that it can be implemented
on the switches so when you when you
select sizes or you select bytes our
current implementation is such that the
first packet of every flow goes to the
controller and no other packets modulo
the network race conditions go to the
controller and so it's very much like
well the kind of implementation you get
out of Stanford they've been working on
these things and we haven't fully
formalized an idea of a cost model but
we I have a vague idea I'd like to work
more on formalizing a cost model that
really makes precise if you have this
query this is exactly the cost in terms
of number of packets diverted from the
fast path and I mean I can sort of say
right now it's approximately 1 packet /
flow well it is one packet / flow if you
don't update the network policy but if
you update the network policy then a bit
of all hell breaks loose because you got
to reorganize how the rules work because
then the new network policy might
intersect differently with the queries
but there we go yep
well so so networks are dynamic things
they change their failures in the
network for example also there are
different modes changes as the changes
so i think that there's a network
program its input as the network
condition Hawaiian give you a fixed
Network program so why isn't there one
program that runs every network in the
world that's your question so not that
week I don't know maybe one network you
just fix it right and you know it runs
that program rotters for a while
so you change your program if you went
from a local area network chances saying
you would like to program to say if I'm
experiencing yeah but I mean these
programs are doing that right I'm
writing queries that monitor the network
that say if the network conditions
change then install this in policy so
you know if there's a failure install
this new policy if I detect through my
monitoring that a certain guy is using
too much bandwidth then drop some of
those packets if you know there's a load
balancer and then it will have been some
database a guy oh I wonder did I have a
service at that and the problem would
change to flipping that fit still you
have the state the pouring rules and
switches yeah the forwarding rule in the
switches sure so I mean if you're at you
know at the beginning there is a bunch
of I mean so there's a lot of companies
Google Facebook Microsoft you know the
list goes on and on who bought into this
new bought into and are supporting this
radical change from you know say
networking five years ago or even three
years ago the idea that they want to be
able to write their own programs to be
able to optimize their data centers or
their corporate networks and you know
here's a couple of applications that
people have looked into I wish mobility
network virtualization dynamic access
control energy efficiency where load
goes down you want to take some switches
off line load balancing there's a lot of
different programs people want to write
to configure these switches I'm giving
you a programming language for doing
that it can be relatively static you can
write a program that
only says here's the one policy that's
it you could write that program but you
can also write programs that are more
dynamic that change depend upon any of
these these these conditions yep I can
think of a different way that I could go
in the abstract direction which is that
I would write my my program as if
estevan programming to switch directly
that is if I had an intelligence which
that is I get some packets and I decide
what to do with them and I keep my eye
on my own counters and then I decide all
from this point on next time I see one
of these Packers I'm not going to let it
through for example and then have the
programming language figure out what of
that program should live on the
controller and when it should register
new things install things on the on the
switch did you consider that so would
you happiest very much something that
when you want to you can install new
quality new cables right on the other
switch but you still have to mentally
think of that distinction there sure so
I think there's two answers for that one
is your version is way harder so because
you know you have to have this compiler
that's really smart they can figure out
given arbitrary code how to generate
things that can go on switches and
actually to a certain extent we did have
that a little bit initially we just had
basically the functional reactive
programming part without the queries but
then we just decided we don't know how
to do this in general and so we gave
them people these limited queries so so
one answer is it's just hard the second
answer is that programmers have more
control over the cost of the programs by
having these explicit parts to query
part and the general-purpose part where
you know the general purpose part runs
in the controller and you know the query
part runs on the
on the on the switches and it's
specifically if your queries don't
return any packets then no packets get
diverted from the fastpass except for
one packet for each flow in our current
runtime system so this is two-part
answer to your question but yeah it
would be interesting for someone who's
really smart to try your approach and to
see to see what would happen I I be I'm
a little skeptical but I haven't tried
it so how would I know any other
questions okay thanks oh yeah have you
ever considered yeah so it Google I mean
this is several startups that are
building distributed controllers with
the goal of handling large data center
networks that's a really interesting
problem but it's just one that we
haven't gotten to yet we wanted to
tackle the problems in the simple
sequential case first before worrying
about you know how to take up up up one
of these programs and paralyzing it
would be it's definitely something on
our list to to think about in the future
but not yet yeah
you